tackling funding and academic
achievement those are just some of the
topics being discussed at this morning's
Las Vegas city council special meeting
Mary Jane bellies are joining us with
possible proposals to change funding for
education
that meeting shows education in Las
Vegas is underfunded and what it should
take to get us to the national average
we know the enormity of this I think
we're exhausted the Nevada Department of
Education and Nevada Commission on
school funding along with applied
analysis providing an overview on the
state's education Christopher Huffman is
the chief strategy officer for the
school district his goal is to get
students to the national average when it
comes to student academic proficiency
it's really difficult to put a specific
number on where we need to be it's just
that we're looking at the progress
that's made so far and what governor
Lombardo's
spending budget looks like a bigger
question is how to funder education
system to meet those goals guy Hobbs
chairs the commission on school funding
you're talking about hundreds of
millions of dollars needed each year of
new Revenue
so it's a very daunting task Hobbs
proposed to fund education through
property sales room and even a cannabis
tax option however at least two-thirds
of the legislature would have to approve
them just to spend to the national
average would require us spending two
two billion dollars more 10 years from
now than we're spending today that means
we have 10 years to continue to monitor
the economy and what kinds of Revenue
sources tax sources might work the best
Jeremy Aguero with applied analysis
discussed how funds should be
distributed per people the dollars must
follow the students and so if the school
district that we're looking at on the
screen were to have been created it
should get the exact same amount of
money that would otherwise would have
received
now also discussed at the meeting school
safety enrollment and resources Brian
Mary Jane thank you now this was just a
presentation from the Las Vegas city
council the legislature will decide on
education funding now the national
average spending per pupil was around
thirteen thousand dollars that's
compared to Nevada at only ninety five
hundred dollars Kirsten